le bonheur est une valeur en hausse les
Français sont plus heureux qu'en 2018
résultat d'une grande étude sur plus de
10 000 personnes dont tout le pays dans
le grand test ils sont même 42% à se
déclarer très heureux un record
d'enthousiasme partagé avec la
Loire-Atlantique bah oui nous sommes
très heureuses n'est pas les filles
j'ai testé de nouvelles choses
aujourd'hui et je trouve qu'elle sont
merveilleuses
infini tes images
qui me parle c'est toi
quand vous avez testé quoi des choses
extraordinaires
est-ce le ton
ou la Vilaine
qui coule en Bretagne c'est quoi la
première proposition le thon ou la
vilaine
la première là le ton
mais toi j'étais à Paris séjour dernier
je me dis que
avec le covid
certainement partagé par les 29% de
Parisiens qui déclarent vouloir
déménager pour chercher le bonheur loin
de la capitale et de sa densité
francilien et provenceau qui ont un
point commun ils sont près de 40 % à
citer les habitants de leur propre
région comme son premier défaut alors
florilège des commentaires de Rachida
Dati micro ouvert pendant l'intervention
Dani dalgo
joindre à l'ensemble des mers qui
viendront à l'Hôtel de Ville ce soir
merci au tour du président Barnier
Baroin pardon mais ça va venir bonsoir
l'exceptionnel s'invitait dans nos vies
mais bien sûr aussi du quotidien d'être
que vous avez quels sont ces choix des
trottoirs
l'ensemble des élus la décentralisation
et l'autonomie et je pense que nous
devons bien sûr non seulement le la
ville du quart d'heure c'est aussi bien
sûr
et nous remboursons aussi notre dette
climatique et au lieu de cela l'état
nous tourne le dos alors face à ce
désengagement à son manque de soutien
la politique c'est comme l'andouillette
ça doit sentir la merde mais pas trop
venez laver c'est le producteur qui m'a
parlé dans l'oreille il m'a dit les gens
s'interrogent vous avez pris quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les oiseaux
sur les oiseaux
vous êtes tout perdu les enfants mais on
est en quelle année là en 1977 au jeune
homme 1977
nom de 13
voilà on s'amuse à la gendarmerie il y a
pas trop de boulot
mardi tu as passé
ce téléphone c'est pour ça qu'on
s'embrouille mardi soir 3h40 sur les
réseaux sociaux 1h21 minutes dans les
voyages je sais pas ce que c'est dans
les voyages je sais pas où tu vois nulle
part et pourquoi toi tu as été que sur
ça ben ouais moi tes réseaux sociaux ils
sont où admettons il a pas mis ses
réseaux sociaux
tableau d'honneur pour les écoliers
français cette année après une chute du
niveau scolaire des enfants en 2020 les
bons résultats sont de retour et parfois
meilleur qu'avant la pandémie voilà le
résultat des évaluations menées sur les
CP les CE1 et les 6e au niveau de HPE
est-ce qu'on appelle HPO potentiel
émotionné au potentiel intellectuel j'ai
un raisonnement différent des autres au
niveau de beaucoup de choses c'est sûr
que si je commence à passer un petit peu
trop de temps avec Marine aussi je vais
avoir un HP négatif
[Musique]
amoureuse
moi j'ai le bac
[Rires]
si on m'avait dit qu'un jour je dirais
Shanna un membre un membre de la famille
royale qui a été si longtemps membre de
la famille royale je crois que j'en
serais pas revenu exemple avec le
français en CE1 les enfants sont testés
sur leur capacité à lire un texte à voix
haute
73,1% un taux de maîtrise satisfaisant
ce taux était de
71,4% en 2019 et avait fortement chuté à
66,6% en 2020 avec la fermeture des
établissements
c'est peut-être vous rendre service je
serai plus intelligente votre côté j'ai
peur de m'ennuyer en fait c'est
tellement dommage que ce mec est pas
tout quand il me parle je réfléchis
genre j'ai l'impression de de d'être en
cours en fait c'est pas possible
j'ai 6 millions de personnes qui me
suivent tu es influenceuse j'aimerais
montrer vraiment qui je suis je reviens
de très loin
j'avais 20 ans on disait que j'étais
bête
aujourd'hui j'ai ma marque cosmétique
j'ai monté un empire j'ai une trentaine
d'employés
j'aimerais si tu me le permets que tu
deviennes la seule l'unique
[Musique]
elle tremble de tous ses membres c'est
beau je suis émue c'est wesh très émue
attends on va faire une pause quand même
pourquoi vous vous mettez dans tous vos
états je sais pas pourquoi mais quand
les gens jouent du piano je ressens les
émotions
bête un tube peut se nicher partout
cette vidéo de chat par exemple inspiré
un musicien ouzbek lui donne le tempo et
des dizaines d'autres utilisateurs de
Tik Tok suivent le rythme et contribue à
ce morceau participatif
[Musique]
tous unis dans un même délire musical